في محيط جنديرس في ريف حلب هل هو الوضع
كذلك كما هو كما رسمه قبل قليل عمر
الحوراني
نعم جمال وفي الواقع لولا الاضاءه التي
نستخدمها في تصوير هذه المقابله لرايتها
او لكان هذا المكان غارقا تماما في الظلام
ساضع الكاميرات اريكم كيف هو حال بعض
العائلات التي شردها الزلزال وهي بعض من
خمسه عشر الف عائله شردها الزلزال شمال
غربي سوريا فلنرى كيف هو مسكنهم واين
ينامون هنا ينامون
على العرش في العراء دون خيمه ودون اي شيء
هناك
هنا ينامون وهنا ايضا ياكلون هنا ماكلوهم
ومشربهم هذا ايضا مسكنهم اما تدفئتهم فهي
بعض من اغصان الزيتون التي يجمعونها من
هذه البساتين التي امامهم عشرات العائلات
في هذا المكان الذي نحن فيه جمال في ريف
جنديرس نقول جنديرس لانها وقبل ان تكلم عن
جنديرس ربما هذا الطفل الصغير هذا الطفل
الصغير انظر كيف ينام في العراء
وهذا الغطاء هو فقط الوسيله لتدفئه هذا
الطفل اتركوا مغطة يا اخي اتركهم غطه
اتركهم
هذا
هذا هو حال عشرات العائلات هنا
[موسيقى]
لا اعرف ان كان الكلام يكون ابلغ من هذه
الصوره جلال لكن هذا هو وضع عشرات
العائلات ووضعها يشبه هذه العائلات التي
نقلنا لكم صورتها هنا قبل قليل على امتداد
هذا الطريق نحو كيلو الى اثنين كيلو متر
الرجال الصغار الكبار النساء يلتحفون
البطانيات من اجل ان تقيهم البرد ودرجه
الحراره الان هي صفر ومع ساعات الليل حسب
توقعات الى مادون الصفر ايضا الناس هنا
على حافه هذا الطريق كلما مرت سياره
وشاحنه يتجمعون حولها ويعتقدون انها شاحنه
مساعدات لكن امالهم في النهايه تخيب هذه
الصور تتشابه في العديد من المواقع في ريف
حلب وفي ريف ادلب كذلك بعض العائلات حظيت
بخيمه
حتى تنتشلهم من هذا الواقع الذي هو فيه
والمنظمات المحليه هنا تكرر وتحذر مرارا
وتكرارا من ان
استمرار وضع هذه العائلات هنا في ريف حلب
قد يؤدي الى حالات وفيات خصوصا الاطفال
والنساء وقد رايت كيف ينام الاطفال الصغار
في هذا المكان هنا على الارصفه كانت هناك
وعود بان هذه المساعدات ستصل قريبا هل وصل
شيء من تلك الوعود اللي هي غافت هؤلاء
الذين يفترشون الارض الان
لايوائهم هل وصلت ايه مساعدات
جمال الحقيقه المساعده اولا هذا او اول
امر اول امر الخيام التي في هذا المخيم
سالنا القائمين في على هذا المخيم من اين
لكم بهذه الخيام اخبرونا بانه مبادرات
محليه قاموا بشراء خيام واوصلوها الى هذه
المنطقه وليس عندهم اموال كافيه حتى يعطوا
الخيام لبقيه الناس هذا واحد اثنين انا
رايت العديد من المنظمات المحليه هنا
اوصلت مساعدات غذائيه او طبيه او اغطيه
الى ما ذلك الى النازحين لكنها قليله
هنالك شاحنات امميه دخله واوصلت عده
شاحنات سواء معبر باب الهواء او باب
السلامه واوصلت العديد من المساعدات لكنها
قليله اعتقد كان العدد ان لم اكن مخطئ نحو
55 شاحنه منذ بدا اصول هذه المساعدات وهذا
ماذا يكفي امام
15,000 عائله مشرده من من الزلزال المدمر
شمال غربي سوريا هي لا تكفي الا قليله فقط
ولا تفي بالحاجه وهذا ما تقوله المنظمات
المحليه هنا وما يقوله كذلك الدفاع المدني
الوضع غايه في السوق جمال والناس في غايه
من الغضب هم كانوا يعتقدون اننا من
المنظمات المحليه ايضا واننا سنقوم بتوزيع
المساعدات عليهم
وقالوا ما الفائده من صورتنا وما الفائده
من ان تنقلوا صورتنا اذا نحن الان في
دخلنا في اليوم الثامن ودون ان تصلنا اي
مساعدات العالم
مره اخرى